un examen de enema de varios o una serie
gastrointestinal inferior es un
procedimiento de rayos-x para visualizar
la anatomía interior del intestino
grueso o colon y recto
y el tracto digestivo consta de la boca
el esófago el estómago el intestino
delgado el colon y el recto los
alimentos atraviesan el tracto digestivo
en ese orden
las funciones principales del colon son
que el cuerpo absorba agua convertir
material de desecho líquido en material
de desecho sólido conocido como heces y
almacenar heces hasta que se acumulen lo
suficiente para pasar por el ano
mediante la defecación
en el colon se pueden desarrollar
condiciones anormales como cáncer de
colon pólipos malformaciones de la pared
del colon llamadas divertículos úlceras
o áreas estrechas conocidas como
estenosis si tiene sangrado sin
explicación dolor abdominal o cambio en
sus hábitos intestinales su médico puede
recomendarle que se realice un examen de
enema de bario
antes del procedimiento se le pedirá que
se recueste sobre una mesa para rayos x-
se le introducirá cuidadosamente un tubo
lubricado en el recto
se adjuntará el tubo una bolsa con
varios
y se dejará que el bario fluya hacia el
colon
cuando haya pasado suficiente barrio al
colon se le pedirá que trate
cuidadosamente de no expulsar nada de
bario mientras se toman las radiografías
es posible que se infle un pequeñísimo
globo adjunto al tubo que contiene el
bario para impedir que el bario se
derrame durante el examen
mientras se toman las imágenes de rayos
x se le pedirá que gire de un lado a
otro o que se ponga de pie esto
permitirá que el bario fluya a
diferentes áreas para poder obtener
imágenes de rayos x de todo el colon
luego de muchas tomas de imágenes de
rayos x se le dará una cuña o se lo
llevará a un baño y se le pedirá que
expulse la mayor cantidad posible de
bario después de que haya expulsado del
colon la mayor parte del bario se pueden
realizar algunas radiografías más ya que
la pequeña cantidad de bario restante
ilumina claramente el contorno del colon
después de la enema de bario puede
regresar a su casa lo más probable es
que pueda reanudar su dieta normal la
mayoría de los radiólogos indica a los
pacientes que aumenten la ingesta de
líquidos durante un periodo de tiempo
para asegurarse de que todo el barrio
sea expulsado es probable que note más
gases que lo habitual y perciba bario en
varias de las defecaciones